[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is like
the video and comment
hey guys in this video we are going to
talk about jon snow's fate in season 8
episode 3 the battle of viralfell
at the end of episode 2 the night king's
army arrived at winterfell
main portion of the living armies are
outside winterfell from the
trekkie to the unsullied and the knights
of the vale vibrio and jaime podrick and
juror waiting for the night king's army
to attack
here above the unsolid in top left
corner you can see two dragons in the
sky
it's regal and drogon and on them are
jon and dany
they will fly out to the near hill to
overlook the battlements and wait for
the night king to come for reign
bran is the niki's target and as we
learned from the war council meeting the
plan is to wait for the night king to
show up at the godswood
theon will be protecting brain and from
the preview we can tell there will be a
lot of action going on
even jon at some point will fight in the
godswood later on
the the checking and the unsullied are
in the middle while the northerners and
the knights of the vale are protecting
flanks
brienne is commanding the left flank
beside her jaime and combined forces of
the knights of the vale and northerners
davos will be on the walls of innerfell
signalizing others when this the right
time to light the trench
and he'll probably take command of the
archers on the walls as well
we also got this shot of sense in the
crypts then we have tyrion lannister and
varys in the crypts as well
lastly in another known capture we see
jon snow deeply concerned even
frightened
he does seem to be looking in the sky
possibly to dany writing dragon
so does this mean something happens to
them they're shut down and john runs
towards them
perhaps we see fire behind him which was
glimpsed in the battlements of nfl in
the first season a trailer
but also in the godswood in the next
time preview so basically in the
beginning of episode 2 john and danny
with their dragons still wait for the
night king to come for brain and then
try to kill him in the godswood
in preview we do see jon in the godswood
but he's on foot
not on dragon it does seem like the
night king has come for brain and john
landed to protect him
but why would jon even land his dragon
many possibilities from his dragon being
killed to dragon fire not being able to
kill the night king
so he's got to land and try to kill him
himself or simply the night king came
too close to brain for jon to use
dragonfire
even though the plan is to wait for the
night king to come for brain i don't
think it's going to be that easy
because i don't think they will see the
night king coming if you have been
watching my videos then you know i have
this crazy theory of the night king not
even being at winterfell
but rather going for king's landing but
that's just a theory
ever since the first season a teaser the
crypts of nfl was released four months
ago have been constantly saying that
night king will use the crypts to attack
vanerfeld from the inside
i believe the night king will use the
crypts of ennerfeld to his advantage and
that they launch attack from inside its
walls
in case you don't know there are hidden
passageways built so the lords of nfl
could escape in emergency
and maester luin actually offered theon
to use it to escape winterfell
and join the night's watchman ramsay
kane i firmly believe that the night
king will use it to attack winner fell
from his side while at the same time
attacking from outside
i also believe we have already seen this
passage in the crypts of nfl teaser for
season 8 where arya is passing through
some tunnel
and i believe the night king will use it
to attack vanerfel from the inside
if the night king uses it then it would
also confirm a popular theory of him
being a stark
because remember those hidden passages
were built for the stark lords
and if he was a stark then he knows
about his secret passage
how crazy would it be if the night king
actually is a stark and bran's line from
the trailer everything you did brought
to you where you're now
where you belong home is actually for
the night king
that would be mind-blowing although bran
is probably saying it the theon greyjay
also in episode 2 it was mentioned way
too many times how the crypts are the
safest place to be
for shadowing it will probably be the
most dangerous place to be
it's going to be safer down in the crypt
said genji toward even trying to
convince her not to fight this battle
when the time comes you'll be down in
the crypts their safest place to be
said gilly to other women we'll put you
in the crypt where it's safest
said john to brain before they made
another plan you'll be in the crypt
commanded dany to tyrion when he wanted
to stay on the wall
they will be saved down in the crypt
replied sam and jon asked about gilly
and little sam
you'll be safer in the crypt said gerard
trying to convince his cousin liana not
to fight against the army of the dead
that six times in one episode main
characters mentioned the crypts of
nfl and how is the safest place to be
meaning that it will most certainly be
one of the most dangerous place to be
some theories the night king will erase
the dead in the crypts but i believe the
night king will actually use secret
passageways to come inside the crypts
and launch an attack from inside similar
to what tyrion did at casterly rock
anyways during the battle it's been
confirmed that jon snow and the night
king will have some kind of one-on-one
fight
vladimir further connector who plays the
night king said and at the same time
spoiled another stare down
between jon snow and the night king that
is set to take place in season 8 episode
3.
thinking back to hardcomb he teases
there's also that moment when jon snow
was on the boat and the night king
looked at him and raised his arms
there's a similar and even stronger
moment between jon and the night king
this time
perhaps this time it will be more
personal maybe this time it's not just
some violins the night king raises from
dead
but it's actually his own family members
from the crypts like for an example
recently this is rickon stark
from the official trailer we can tell
for sure that tary and jon will be
fighting fiercely for their home
and something likely the dead starks
resurrected by the night king from the
crypts will chase zarya through the host
of nfl
but let's get a bit back and see how
kurevaria got herself in this situation
so what happens is that jaime probably
see a bunch of whites breaching the
crypts of nfl
or the gods with the winterfell wherever
bran is at that moment
jimmy sees it and so he shouts brain to
someone likely to arya as a warning that
her brother's life is in danger then
jaime and arya probably run to defend
brain
so jaime and arya go for bran who is
probably accompanied by sam
and this right here might be arya and
behind her jaime and sam pushing brain
as they all run for something says jaime
and samco are pushing brain in his
wheelchair will not be as quick as arya
she will try and distract that something
from them
running the other way and that way
saving brain and this is a clip of her
doing it
and here we can actually see what's
chasing her in this slide-end version if
you look closely you can notice that she
looks to be pursued by something with a
skeletal face
judging by the scared look of arya i
have the feeling that she is running
from something that came from
inside the crypts the dead starks keep
in mind that arya does not fear death
should stand and fight anyone or
anything arya would not be afraid of
whites or white walkers
as she's actually fighting those in the
trailer she would not run from them
especially since she is holding a knife
made out of dragonglass which kills them
i think the one chasing her or at least
one among them is her brother rickon
who died at the battle of the bastards
and was buried in the cribs below winner
fell
arya sees undead rickon she cries and is
not able to fight him so she runs
i think here arya will be killed but the
good news is she will then probably be
resurrected by beric dondarrion
in the books barrick died then he gave
his life to bring back kathleen stark
that's what his purpose was in the books
and that's why he was brought back to
life so many times
in the show i think he'll have the same
story more or less
i think he will give his life to bring
back one of the starks who are going to
die during this battle
tweeter arya with whom he has had quite
a history and even was on her kill list
for some time
or sensa who looks and acts just like
her mother who he resurrected in books
beric survived this long for a reason
and he has been revived so many times
for a reason
and has been highlighted multiple times
throughout season 7 and season 8.
he will give his life to bring back one
of the starks that's going to be killed
by bywalkers
beric was brought back so many times for
a reason and we learn why exactly when
he gives his life to one of the starks
that's going to be killed by the night
king
perhaps here the hound and beric in the
holes of nfl are searching for arya
who will earlier be chased by whites why
walker said him possibly by the night
king himself
only to find her dead lying on the floor
that's when beric would give his life to
bring her back
jon snow will fight hard but he will not
be able to win this battle
winter will not fall at winterfell and
josslyn will probably have to burn down
his home to the ground but the good news
is jean will survive
the night king winning this battle was
teased by winner felt easier
in which we see stark's ancestral home
in ruins and abandoned with the night
king entering through its gates
this battle will be a huge defeat for
the living from leaked photos we can
tell winterfell is on fire
the night king has won there's a
possibility that the night king uses
some kind of magic
or even he's done that dragon viserion
to burn down benefal
but i actually think it's the living who
burns it down either on purpose or he
catches some fire by itself
from all the fire they use to kill
whites if it's on purpose then i can
definitely see john using regal to burn
down winterfell
after they're forced to retreat why
would jon burn down his home
well if they lost it means there's tens
of thousands corpses laying inside and
outside winterfell
you know what happens to those who died
they become part of the night king's
armies and the living cannot allow those
numbers to get any higher
so after they lose most of their armies
the living will probably make a decision
to retreat and run
and they're going to have to burn
winterfell to make sure the army of the
dead doesn't grow
john will most likely have to burn down
his home
this was foreshadowed by ed when he told
to john and sam last man left
burned the rest of us after this epic
battle of nfl the night king will
conquer the north
and jon snow along with all the
survivors will have to retreat south
and we have known for more than a month
where exactly that's going to be
one of the teasers provided this shot of
dany standing in front of a fireplace
with her back turned to jon and details
on that fireplace confirmed that they
are genustone
i've already talked too much about it in
my previous videos but in case you
missed it here's how we know it's
dragonstone
take a look at all the details on this
shot from the fireplace itself to its
props
the stone curves and the metal work it's
the same thing we already saw at
genostone
so now we know they'll retreat to
dragonstone in episode 4 after
winterfell falls to the night king in
episode 3.
in conclusion episode 3 is going to be a
massacre but the good news is jon snow
survives and retreats to dragonstone
the bad news is that many other
characters will die jon snow will have a
one-on-one with the night king and he
will not manage to kill him
the plan to use bran as a bait in the
godswood will not go well
theon will probably die protecting him
and even john will have to land there
and that's the place he'll most likely
fight the night king vanerfeld will fall
and jon snow will have to burn it down
by using his dragon rhaegal
to prevent all the dead from becoming
part of the night king's armies
episode 3 is going to be a survival
horror and one cannot simply wait for
tomorrow night
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace
you